welcome to the order flows market review
for Wednesday May twenty-fifth 2016 my
name is Michael vatos i'm the founder of
order flows calm first a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision futures trading
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
training and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading as
performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results okay
there's three trades i took this morning
in june SNP's one in the bonds to or
winners one was a loser I'll just walk
you through it these are the order flows
trader or software charge really it's a
software it runs on ninja trader you
know if you don't have a ninja trader
you should look into it go visit
ninjatrader calm they have a ton of
software add-ons that you could use for
your trading and this is the one that
I've developed this morning where this
is just about after nine o'clock we had
made a new high in the SPS and we're
seeing very good volume trade here you
see you know seven thousand being lifted
on the offer of 2,000 5,000 4,000 3000 I
got in here at 87 2087 and as you know I
was really looking for a nicer move up
rather quick and you know it didn't
happen even those bars since it closed
at 90 for you know my entry was earlier
in the bar at closer to about eight just
before nine and yeah except you know
I've seen a lot of buying up here which
is fine and I was expecting the market
to sort of find a level where that's you
know some thin that volume was going to
be occurring it didn't happen we just
kept running into offer to offer it to
offer it to offer and to offer I got out
a bit prematurely I got a half a point
in twenty eighty seven and a half and we
had traded up to 88 I was really looking
for a quick move up to eighty nine and a
half in which we did shortly after I got
out but nevertheless you know I got out
here then then was proven right but the
reason I got out is because he kept
trading up here putting a volume coming
off trading volume coming back off you
know it's at some point a move is going
to end and it's going to be heavy volume
often you know at the end of the move
and you could just see as you're going
up you know again heavy volume heavy
volume heavy volume I just got tired of
fighting it so I took a small small
profit looking back I was a bit
premature you know I didn't necessarily
trail my stop you know if I trail my
stop myself over here at 87 we didn't
necessarily come back but in trading you
have to make those decisions you want to
get out there you still want to just
fight it what I was looking for was more
something along lines of this bar here
where you just see thin volume and then
you can write up to the profit target
this volume was was a clue to me to get
in but really the real clue you can't
see it now because we put in more volume
here but earlier in this bar we had a
nice big fat find a balance of over
4,000 you know later we put in after I
got in here at 87 we traded a bit here
some volume at six and three-quarters
and the mine imbalance went away but
still you know I felt it was fairly
strong very strong reason to get into
the trade I said I was looking for a
quick move didn't really develop so you
know I took what I could get out of it
which was half a point now looking back
I could have got more out of it okay the
second trade was in the bonds and it
didn't work out it was those a lawsuit
was five take loss what happened it is I
got short off this Delta scalper you
know we actually made a swing high here
at the we came back up to the opening
price for the day that's this yellow
line and you know it wound up
we hit the hive and a diver I sorry Anna
ratio that I like have another ratio of
the Delta scalper I didn't take the
trade initially this first time because
as soon as this bar finished we got the
buying going right in the you know
opposing direction you know had I taken
it as the trade here yeah I would have
also been stopped out we trade it back
right up to this opening price however
we started coming off again you see the
Delta is building up you know 94 800
again I got the Delta scalper kicking
off this bar had a strong negative Delta
I just went ahead got short here at 24
when I stopped him just behind this
point of control which was 28 that
putting in at 29 the market rally back
up to 29 actually got all the way up to
31 although it early it hit 29 you know
tricky like nine lots which you know
which I was I was five and then it came
back down to 28 and you know 27 but then
eventually it went back up this one this
market you know we came off again you
know after stopping out we came back
down to 25 before turning around and
going back up so you know that's why you
have to have stops in the market there's
gonna be times where it just goes
against you you can you know have what
you think is the best entry but you
don't know after you click buy or sell
you know there's gonna be somebody there
with a big order going in the opposite
direction really you got very strong
Delta minus 800-900 practically the
market you'd expect to sell off a bit
more not not rally but nevertheless it
did and stop me out but in trading you
have to learn to take your losses okay
this last trade was in the on a 10 or a
shard in the e minis the first train I
took in the minis was based on a five
range the second chart was not was on a
tender age when you're looking at a ten
range chart obviously you have more data
involved and sometimes of the moves
you're going to get are they look
stronger so what we did is we made our
high here around nine thirty came off
we have a divergence which is an equal
or new high with a negative Delta then
the next bar a very strong negative
Delta minus eight thousand you know
together these two are you know it's
practically minus ten thousand which
I'll get to in a minute this next bar
that we're in here this one at 1004
which turned up at a positive Delta
however at one point it was minus 2 458
again which is strong so you see minus
two thousand minus eight thousand and
this party at minus two and a half
thousand at that moment into an offer
here at 2089 which is just ahead of this
point of control I was really looking
for a pullback towards this point of
control test it maybe get through it by
a couple points I have a couple ticks
and then sell off and we got back up
towards it you know my entry was here at
2089 we got I got filled I threw in
another offer at 90 right up in here I
really felt very strongly about this
trade you know I'm not advocating just
because you have a lawsuit crease your
size but you know this is a 10 range
chart I have a much longer much longer
view as I was expecting to hold this I
was really expecting the bigger move
down below you know 84 at a minimum so
what happens is you know we do pop up
through it we get back up to around this
point of control here and we get up to
this point of control at 90 and a half
you know this was another key level to
watch you know the first level the watch
was was going to be this point of patrol
you know as the market is going to go
down if you think the markets going down
points in control are going to act as
your support or resistance know if you
think it's going down it's going to act
as your resistance so we got to the
first one okay we got through it a
little bit so the next one I want to
watch the hold is this one here at 2950
and when you're thinking of support and
resistance it's not always going to be
one particular price levels gonna be
arranged especially if you're trying to
get in on a pole back so we got up to
this one and you know it was couraging
because we stopped just one tick on the
other side only trade 155 then you see
selling come and you see selling the
balance element balance
so I thought oh happy days I'm going to
come down you're just going to you know
the selling is taking over you got a
very strong negative Delta we weren't
into this bar and we just stall out as
bars is trading it takes over an hour to
form power in 10 minutes you know but
you're seeing heavy volume again it's
got a negative Delta sellers are still
in control however you know the thing
that that caused me to get out I got out
here at Edmondson down here at 84 was it
was the first level that i was looking
at and I got out though at at 87 in 87
and a half because this bar took a long
time to form and oftentimes one of our
takes a long time to form come out of it
in the market moves pretty quick in a
certain direction usually in the same
direction however in this case we were
stalling out we were putting in now
we're putting in some volume here and
Mark II wasn't going any lower you have
all this extra selling excess you know
six and a half thousand negative Delta
he got 19,000 trading at 87 10,000 at
eighty six and three-quarters where's
the follow-through it got through it but
then we hit another level at six and a
half and you know six in the quarter
where there was strong volume this time
you know I got into the trade of 10 it's
ready two hours later you know and we're
still only trading a couple points
better so I I just said I better just
take what i can and i got out at 87 87
and a half now there was you know
offense me I honestly haven't looked
into what the Fed speaker said but in
the market in reaction the market did
react to this this level here you know
when we're getting like I said if it's
going to be support and resistance you
know these points controls if we start
spending a lot of time above this point
of control this previous point of
control it's going to have a higher
propensity to keep going up and in which
it did you know I think there was some
mitigating factors there you know I
don't watch the news I don't follow the
news and trade around the news but I'm
aware of you know when someone from the
Fed is speaking so you know if if I
start seeing the market
activity pick up in a certain direction
if I'm in a trade I don't usually like
to be trading around it this one is
ready in my favor and I felt that maybe
I can get a little bit of a push but you
know the really the sign that it wasn't
working out was we were just starting to
try to trade higher and higher and
higher and you know you're trading above
your previous point of control you know
if you're trading you know more volume
below its ok that's fine but if you're
if you're trading starting to put in
some good volume above the previous
point of control then this one is going
to be acting as support it's not going
to be the resistance because they lose
resistance we would trade up around it
and come off you know not going to trade
put and start putting a lot of volume
above this point of control and then the
market went up tested the eyes came off
a bit went back up made new high started
coming off and you know this is already
Wednesday night you know we did finally
get down to my level but you know i'm
not i'm definitely not claiming you know
it's nice to see that the market did go
to my favor but you know the market went
up here you know took out the high you
know initially on the straight i had to
stop in at two and a half which is
actually that the high that we got to
but what was interesting about this
highest you got up there and you have
some very strong volume 1500 you know
1100 you can see 1200 sold into the bid
it's not a ratio that i have in terms of
a blue number however you know it's
point seven one you know on the settings
that i use for the indicator i use point
699 because i want to see a ratio of
point seven and below so you can see it
in in the settings 0.6 99 now if i had
it set up a point 75 yeah it would show
it's it's a borderline number however
you know what's important you know even
though it's not a ratio that I like I do
think that this highs has a good chance
to hold for the next day or two simply
because it's a decent volume up there
usually you come into the high you see
325 241 these are I'm talking about the
red candles degree
candles you just power up through the
highs you know 482 703 but the number
that you see here that occurred in the
afternoon now it's 1500 it's a decent
number this level you know the market
reacted to it and we're trading now ten
points off that high right now so we'll
see what today's day will you know how
it will develop and you know if there's
going to be a bit more of a bit more
sell-off you know this was that was the
extent of the move that I was looking
for you know somewhere down to the
eighty four ish level initially off of
this high the fact that we made this
second high here with some decent volume
followed up by some price rejection
numbers these ratios indicating price
rejection as well and the market came
right off so those were the three trades
that's that I took today it was kind of
a slow day you know it started out
pretty quickly really look like the
market was was moving pretty freely
after in cash open we did you know from
830 up to up to 9 30 you know we had a
nice move up a very nice move especially
here at 847 up to 9 30 but then after
that it that's when I quiet it down you
can see this excited when you see bars
taken a long time to formulas bar over
an hour it's it's a sign of you know
trading occurring at a fair price you
can't say absorption absorption would be
no buyers and sellers being evenly
matched but we're spending a lot of time
training in one bar that you know people
are happy to transact you see volumes
here ten thousand thirteen thousand
nineteen thousand ten thousand fifteen
thousand thirteen thousand twelve
thousand you know this area in the air
people were happy to transact at that
time this bars got 170 thousand which is
just very strong for one bar on 10 rate
chart now if you're looking at a five
range dark you know your charge is going
to be flat line going across it's
basically trading in a two-point range
for over an hour okay so thank you for
watching this video to learn more about
try
eating with order flow and the software
that I use in this video be sure to
visit my website w-w-whoa fellows calm
again the software runs on ninja trader
so if you don't have a ninja trader you
should check it out and I think it's one
will help a lot of people in their
training you send me an email if you
have any questions about this video my
name is my email is my cat order flows
calm it's right up here so thanks again
and see you on the inside